foreign
new tonight a tiny Texas town of about
250 people has 50 sworn police officers
200 a town with 250 people has 50 police
officers that seems like a bit much
for every five people
talking about coffee City that's up in
Henderson County some three hours north
of Houston they have one cop for every
five residents and what's more Jeremy
Rogowski discovered many of them no no
no no do you know this is corrupt
there's something corruptive
am I right Virgie you sent it wait oh
wait those officers have a history of
problems wearing the badge
on the banks of Lake Palestine some
three hours north of Houston this dot on
the map has quite a reputation among
those who drive through so it's like
speech like Golden Beach like Golden
Beach in South Florida
yeah literally everywhere Golden Beach
from back and forth back and forth a lot
of officer is policing a very small
number of people only 249 people says
the sign on the edge of town it's insane
when you add up all the full-time cops
and reserves 50 officers good Lord
all right man you like to see homos
naked it's crazy I like this it's such a
small town why do we need so many makes
no sense
why you need that many officers coffee
City hauled in a million dollars
all right that was kind of that was kind
of a cool effect yeah coffee City 100
brought in a million dollars in the same
way Golden Beach is this Golden Beach in
Florida is like this like where it's a
tiny like it's a one two mile by Two
Mile town it's very small by the beach
but you have to drive through on A1A so
if you go 32 over they'll [__] pull
you over give you a ticket they don't
give a [__]
there's in court fines last year for
more than 5 000 violations officers
wrote the most in the state for a town
its size so they take all this federal
and state money uh spend it on officers
and then the town just like Pockets a
million which wouldn't even pay for the
officers correct this this [__] gets so
much worse okay but this isn't a story
about a small town riding a bunch of
tickets you see coffee city is a magnet
for troubled cops somebody grew up uh
somebody grew up liking John Stossel a
magnet yeah oh god oh boy you're right
you're right this guy's like wants to be
John Stossel I'll tell the way he talks
to the shitty covers you know what I'll
take I would love I take that good no no
I like this guy but I'm just saying this
guy like John stop saying a lot by the
end of this video You're gonna [__]
love this guy okay on writing a bunch of
tickets you see coffee city is a magnet
for troubled cops how do we know
ku-11 investigates obtain Personnel
records from oh yeah other police
agencies really found more than half of
coffee City officers had been suspended
demoted terminated or dishonorably
discharged from their previous job okay
now that's different hold on that is
like one of those this is like one of
those parishes where they sent like all
the child molesters yeah dude so this
isn't I will say this this is not like
Golden Beach because Golden Beach quite
the opposite to work at Golden Beach you
have to have like served at other police
departments from like Immaculate record
like it's you want that gig you want the
Golden Beach cake because it's an easy
gig this is I also don't have Golden
Beach also doesn't have 500 police
officers good point oh yeah good point
yeah
a dozen were even criminally charged I
was astounded to think that they've been
hired by another agency Greg Freeman is
a Sam Houston State criminal justice
professor and retired Houston Police
their prior discipline ranges from
excessive force to public drunkenness on
truthfulness an association with known
criminals oh charges include DWI theft
aggravated assault violence and
endangering the child you know my God
you know we we talk about shitty like
Mercy brought up the other uh things
earlier like the uh the graphics was
cool and this is pretty cool let's give
it because we see a lot of shitty local
news let's give it a k a k Houston 11.
yeah this is good
if you know hey uh other news people
do what the do you think those guys do
this please they're hiring an officer
that has a very troubled past in history
and has no business to be wearing a
uniform and it's a very very precarious
slope that that's well sorry Frozen that
he is engaging in by hiring this is the
man who hired them
Chief John Jay Portillo quadrupled the
Department's size since he took the job
to what so he's doing favors for other
departments guaranteed two years ago he
says to provide 24 7 coverage for the
town no you do not need 50 people 50
cops or 250 people you do not 10 you
need 10 cops
maybe maybe 20.
why would no because I'm talking also
office jobs
you know yeah I guess you hire so many
people with all these red flags there's
more to just what's on paper no that's
literally all you go on when you
prosecute people
and that's where I rely on my captain
and my background investigators to go in
and dig and say hey what's up what's the
truth behind this the chief says
criminal charges were often dismissed of
course because cops look out for each
other it's honorable discharges
overturned he claims most applicants
hired got on the wrong side of the
agency politics
oh okay uh guys they were on the wrong
side of agency politics yes go back to
the totality of a lot of these officers
stuff I would say 75 or not more they're
being retaliated against from their
agency retaliate why would you take a
chance chief
I tried to look at the good this guy
rules and I believe everybody there's an
opportunity you give a lot of
opportunities I don't know who this
reporter is but I want more of his stuff
yes we do yes we do the opportunity to
wear a badge allows his officers to work
extra jobs which can mean real money
fifty dollars an hour or more for
overtime I mean that's not hide it from
anybody they're making probably about
80. they're making sorry Virgie they're
making 80 to 100K a year no it gets
worse it gets so much worse so [__]
not they he was putting them down for
full time so that they could go work
those other jobs that were being con
where they were Contracting police but
they weren't working full-time it's a
[__] town of 250 people and there's
[__] cops for every five people
does he get a cut of his officer's extra
job wages twice during our interview the
chief said no the only money he makes
from extra jobs is from the ones he
works himself and that takes us from
coffee City to Houston and what's coming
up oh this is great yeah I just read
ahead a little bit a story about this so
like half a dozen of these cops that are
full-time weren't even working in coffee
City they were working from home in
Houston
hold on hold on we got more videos
coming
coffee City Texas a small town of about
250 people and 50 police officers on the
force our investigative team dug through
records and found half of those officers
had been suspended demoted or fired from
previous jobs some even criminally
charged Jeremy Rogowski discovered the
man who hired them can have a short fuse
when dealing with others who wear the
best oh really here in Harris County
yeah coffee City's police chief so this
is Jeremy Rogowski we gotta remember
this miles away at this Houston
apartment complex and on this day watch
how John Jay Portillo behaved so there's
the guy that was like I find the good in
people right this is the same guy
version I find the good in people okay
Garcia and tell him he's going to be the
next election it's called Garcia tell me
he's going to be [__] this next
election oh is that the weird pop
Department politics you were talking
about earlier an expletive-filled rant
launched at the elected Constable of
Harris County Precinct 2 Jerry Garcia
Grateful Dead
assaulted him at the complex it was just
one of many requests the Constable says
kept coming in from off-duty coffee city
cops which at first was you know no big
deal we help anybody and everybody but
then we noticed that it was becoming a
pattern that pattern the Constable says
was draining resources so Garcia reached
out to the Harris County District
Attorney's office and we were advised to
tell Chief Portillo that he had to file
the charges but when deputies did you
mayor riots ride two dollars actual
journalism is jarring in 2023. it is it
really is right like I'm intrigued this
is what journalists should be what's
that Portillo left a nasty voicemail and
uh
whatever those numbnuts are that you
have working for you uh you know tell
them your guys out it saddened me it
upset me hear that this isn't something
small this is I mean this is pretty
upsetting what upset the Constable even
more the responses agency got back after
alerting coffee City's mayor I don't see
very much there that warrants any
disciplinary action from the city the
mayor wrote the officers are contracted
by the property for off-duty police
protection you may want to reach out to
them with any complaints I didn't think
that it merited any disciplinary action
against him it's it's crazy Greg Freeman
is a Sam Houston State criminal justice
professor and retired Houston Police
Captain basically that's you're enabling
bad behavior now and that's exactly what
the mayor has done so what does chief
Portillo have to say for himself if I
was amped up
and I apologize to my city council not
city council did you apologize to
Constable Garcia no I haven't had a
chance I haven't what do you mean you
have his phone number the cussing
incident happened six months ago six
months ago and he didn't have a chance
to apologize to the constable
is that the real John Jay portugu that
people are seeing in this video no I
don't I don't just go off the handle
well you did here yeah because
[Laughter]
and I was upset because I could they
wouldn't you know they wouldn't do what
I told them to do
also this I'm a five-star man typical
copper he's a [__] idiot these guys
[__] corrupt idiot yeah let me follow
the targets it's not the only example we
found that calls into questions
I know oh really there's more and
integrity and his application to become
coffee City's chief he never listed this
a DWI charge out of Florida in which he
failed to appear in court
oh
wait he pulled a Dutch
why wouldn't you disclose actually
didn't disclose it was over 10 years ago
this is does it matter
you had an accident Warren huh that was
disposed of no it wasn't court records
after our interview Portillo hired a
Florida defense attorney who filed a not
guilty plea in the case
well well well
the sky looks of it you weren't being
truthful on the application to which you
hold the job this day
Chief yeah Chief hello
I'm not being truthful
but you are
just I Plum forgot everything that was
in my mind when I filled out my
application the best of my knowledge
well that same job application states
there are criminal consequences for
relying on it well there can't possibly
be any more
obligation leads to changes that a Texas
Police Department we've showed you how
the town of coffee City three hours
north of Houston is a magnet for cops
with troubling backgrounds now the chief
is temporarily shutting down a division
that works here in Harris County after
Jeremy Rogowski
really question of whether time for the
sheriffs to come in because that's what
happens when they shut down Police
Department the sheriff comes in and
takes over it's legal
coffee City Texas
dot on the map with barely 250 residents
as a police force of 50 officers all
right guys you're overusing that cops
than any other Texas town its size and
that's not the only thing unusual or odd
turns out there are a half dozen
full-time coffee City police officers
who don't even work in coffee City Texas
it's your sammers
instead they work from home more than
three hours and nearly 200 miles away
that's awesome it's hard to believe that
that is happening Greg Freeman how do
you work from home as a cop a Sam
Houston State criminal justice Professor
I've never seen anything like that there
are a hundred questions that come to my
mind who are these officers this
internal email shows they're part of a
warrant division it reads there is no
need to go to coffee City because you
will be spending 95 percent of your time
on the phone calling people who have
outstanding warrants and collecting
failure to appear fines and because it
it's a full-time position there's an
added perk because of the ability to go
work our extra job coffee City chief
John J Portillo concedes there on the
books as full time because state law
only allows full-time cops to work extra
security jobs at this Houston apartment
complex some coffee City warrant
officers do just that and make more than
fifty dollars an hour
just
unbelievable bro what if I told you it
actually gets worse it can't possible
come on man
two three days a week four days a week
but is it all above board the warrant
division is a performance-based division
and officers pay is based on the failure
to appears they collect oh my God it's
like [__] with telemarketing yeah
you're working for collection agency
Freeman says that amounts to a
commission for collecting fines it
doesn't make any sense from an ethical
perspective it it just screams questions
about the legitimacy of what they're
doing that's because state law requires
full-time peace officers to get paid at
least at the federal minimum wage but
again at the coffee City warrant
division the Court gives them 150 for
each warrant that they clear so they
don't earn a salary apart from that
hundred and fifty dollars no sir no sir
ahead correct yeah correct okay is that
legal
this guy
[__] rules
good for this guy I believe so
you're the cop you need to know the law
that's your job yeah two days after our
interview coffee City PD changed course
sending out this email to Warrant
detectives that said due to unforeseen
difficulties the program has been
suspended until such time
I like that he just keeps like reacting
like this cops the equivalent of the guy
that like keeps deleting going back to
Leading like tweets and [__] that are
already archived holy [__] dude this is
crazy yeah this is whose job is it to
police the police the Department of
Public Safety enforces any extra job
well there's an amendment violations the
Texas commission on law enforcement or
chico has the power to suspend or revoke
a peace officer's license that agency
confirms to us it does have an open
investigation into the coffee City Place
Jeremy thing that's it oh my my God this
is crazy holy [__] I was gonna say it's
Rabbit Hole got deeper and deeper Virgie
keep an eye on this any update I need
any any anything that's amazing and
check out more of this guy's work I like
this guy yeah this Rogowski guys this
guy [__] dude even to his hand like
his hand mannerisms and stuff through
he's he's a Stossel yeah
he's wearing the Stossel shirt jacket he
was right you're right